Joe Biden absolutely dominated last
night's primaries all the results aren't
yet in but it looks like a clean sweep
Biden won at least four of the six
states in a contention he overwhelmed
Bernie Sanders by more than 15 points in
the key state of Michigan everyone in
Washington now assumes as a matter of
faith that Biden will be the Democratic
nominee and they are thrilled by this
just incredibly and profoundly relieved
that Bernie Sanders has been subdued the
lawrence O'Donnell doesn't live in
Washington but he might as well
O'Donnell is a walking Vesuvius of
conventional wisdom when lawrence
o'donnell speaks he's speaking for the
entire self-satisfied political class
here's his conclusion on Joe Biden his
opening line was this is your campaign
and he did it in the most generous ways
he could he had a very soft tone of
voice a very as if you're in the living
room with him he really was trying to
create
I think comfort stability talked about
presidential leadership
he said if you give me the honor of
becoming your present and Joe Biden's
use of that word honor which at any
other time I think would be a throwaway
line in a political speech for me had
some real resonance honor the awe you
could hear the joy in his voice this is
the Atheist party's version of Christmas
what they're happiest about is the
voting as effectively order voting is
the democracy portion of the process and
it's by far their least favorite part
but that's over with now on to the
convention on to the inauguration and
best of all on to power that's what
they're thinking right now but there's a
problem the election is still 237 days
away in the context of a presidential
campaign that's an awfully long time Joe
Biden is right now about as popular as
he's ever gonna be both polling and
primary results though so far suggests
that Biden does best with voters who
don't follow politics very closely and
haven't thought about the race very much
they know Biden's name they know he once
worked for Barack Obama you know he
isn't that radical and scary guy from
Vermont so the trick for the DNC at this
point is to make
certain they never learned more than
that Democrats would love to go all the
way to November without allowing Biden
out of the house but they can't do that
it's too obvious so they'll have to let
him campaign to some limited extent
every time Joe Biden leaves a suburban
his entire candidacy hangs in the
balance
will he brag about the time he went to
Burning Man with Martin Luther King we
mistake his wife for the governor of
Oregon we threatened to punch out a cop
you just don't know with Biden anything
is possible
the whole thing makes them very very
nervous last night Congressman Jim
Clyburn of South Carolina suggested the
DNC ought to step in immediately and
cancel any more debates if the night
ends the way it has begun I think it is
time for us to shut this primary down
it's time for us to cancel the rest of
these debates because you don't do
anything but get yourself in trouble if
you continue this contest when there's
obvious that the numbers will not see it
out for you we got to shut it down right
away lock him in the basement till
November and clapeyron didn't say that
lightly he knows the math at the last
democratic debate Joe Biden spoke for
about 1/7 of the total time at the
debate this Sunday he'll speak for
roughly half the total time and if
you're Joe Biden that's a lot of time
that's a lot of chances to scare the
hell out of prospective voters and if
you're the Biden campaign speaking at
all in public is mostly downside so you
can imagine the pressure on Bernie
Sanders trying to drop out before any of
that can happen as of now Sanders has
not caved and actually you can see why
he's not caving Biden is very likely to
win the nomination but he doesn't yet
have it in fact he's barely halfway to
the majority of Delegates Sanders could
stay in the race for a while and that's
not an entirely crazy strategy at this
point honestly who knows what could
happen
anyone who believes that Joe Biden will
absolutely no question at all be the
Democratic nominee in November hasn't
been watching American politics for the
last four years that appears to be
Bernie's position Donald Trump must be
defeated and I will do everything in my
power to make that happens on Sunday
night in the first one-on-one debate of
this case
Payne the American people will have the
opportunity to see which candidate is
best positioned to accomplish that goal
so the last point is a fair point
America has the right to see Joe Biden
answer questions on stage if we're up to
the Stooges on cable television
Biden would be the president already no
election but hold on for a second not so
fast before we make any rash decisions
that could alter the course of American
history forever let's take a long close
look at the Democratic candidate the
presumptive nominee is he really ready
for this we'll get a better idea on
Sunday